we have rank structures in our companies
and so I know who outranks me and I know
where I sit in the pcking order um and
when someone outranks me we show
difference right um like if you're a
senior and you left your coat in the
other room someone will go get your coat
for you and if you're a junior and you
left your coat in the other room you
getting your own coat that's just how it
works right and if somebody famous or
somebody that you know that is
recognizable so social status now you'll
hold the door open for them and you'll
come home and you leave and be like I
help the door open for Steven Spielberg
you know like you're going to brag about
doing something for someone that they
can perfectly well do themselves because
we like to do things for people who
outrank Us in the social hierarchy right
um and so once we assess that someone is
Alpha to us we we show difference and so
we allow our Alphas to eat first our
Alphas get first choice of meat and
first choice of mate so I may not got to
eat first but I'm guaranteed a meal and
I don't get a elbow in the face good
system for cooperation
right um and this exists today by the
way um if you are senior in the
organization you'll get a better parking
space you'll get a nicer office you'll
get a higher salary and no one
absolutely zero people are morally
offended by those perks not a single
human being is morally offended that
someone who's more senior than you in
the organization gets a higher salary we
might think you're an
idiot but we're not morally offended by
it right but here's the best part
the group is not dumb we don't give our
Alphas all these perks for nothing just
cuz you're senior there's a deep-seated
social
contract that when danger threatens the
tribe the person who's actually stronger
actually smarter actually better fed
there's an expectation that you're going
to rush towards the danger to protect us
that's why we gave you all those perks
they are not
free and so we don't mind that our
senior people have more but when danger
threat with the organization we want to
know that you're going to protect us
even sometimes before yourself and then
we will give you our love and our
loyalty where the social contract breaks
down is when the leader putss first so
we've seen this happen many of times
when there's scandals in organizations
where a leader makes tons of money which
we don't mind but when there is a bad
economy they announce huge L rounds of
layoffs
and the leader keep keeps their fat
salary or worse there's no bad economy
we just missed our arbitrary
projections that we told the analysts so
we're very profitable just not as
profitable as we promised so you lose
your job and that's where the outrage
comes from the outrage comes from the
fact that youve violated the deep-seated
social contract so the reason I say
leadership is difficult and the reason I
say leadership requires courage is
because we all want the perks of
leadership but how many of us are
willing to fulfill our responsibility as
leaders and that's an entirely different
subject and where you command love and
loyalty is if people feel seen people
feel heard people feel understood people
feel like they matter and that you care
about them as a human being and that
they don't care they'll give you all the
difference in the world